[Música]
Buenos días y bienvenidos a la
entrevista de France 24 nuestro invitado
de hoy es el enviado especial de Estados
Unidos a Irán Robert Mali que nos
acompaña desde el departamento de
Estados Unidos en Washington DC
Gracias por invitarme
Irán está atravesando lo que algunos han
llamado una ola de protestas sin
precedentes desde que una mujer de 22
años llamada maxam y murió el 16 de
septiembre tras ser detenida por la
policía de la moral enterando por no
usar correctamente el velo obligatorio
a pesar de la consiguiente y brutal
represión las protestas han continuado
especialmente el pasado miércoles que se
cumplieron 40 días de su muerte el final
del período de luto en Irán Usted dijo
recientemente que los manifestantes se
manifestaban para que el gobierno
respetara sus abro comillas derechos
humanos cierro comillas pero parece que
exigen algo más que respeto dicen muerte
al dictador parece que quieren un cambio
de régimen
en primer lugar como usted mencionó Hoy
es un día muy importante para muchos en
Irán es un día que marca 40 días desde
la brutal muerte de Max amínica mientras
estaba bajo la custodia de la llamada
policía de la moral hay manifestaciones
en todos los rangos manifestaciones de
personas que han mostrado persistencia
valor creatividad frente a una brutal
represión y corriendo un gran riesgo
personal
nuestros ojos están puestos en lo que
está ocurriendo allá y más adelante
hablaré de las acciones que hemos tomado
hoy para sancionar a los responsables de
la represión usted se refirió a algo que
dije corregir inmediatamente lo que dije
al día siguiente porque no me
corresponde a mí ni al gobierno de
Estados Unidos caracterizar Cuáles son
las aspiraciones del pueblo iraní o de
los manifestantes iraníes un solo ellos
pueden hacerlo lo que podemos hacer es
apoyarlos apoyar sus derechos
fundamentales y sancionar y denunciar a
quienes utilizan la violencia extrema
para reprimirlos eso es lo que hemos
estado haciendo junto con esfuerzos para
garantizar que los iraníes tengan acceso
a internet para que puedan hablar entre
ellos y comunicarse con el mundo
exterior usted mencionó las sanciones la
administración vaiden ha impuesto
algunas sanciones la Unión Europea
también es suficiente o se están
preparando más sanciones porque como
hemos dicho la protesta continúa la
represión continua
mos mientras hablamos justo en este
momento estamos anunciando una serie de
nuevas sanciones que van a estar
dirigidas a los líderes de la guardia
Revolucionaria islámica que han estado
directamente involucrados en la
represión en todo el país funcionarios
de prisiones que han sido responsables
en particular en la conocida presión de
evinn y estamos examinando en todos los
niveles funcionarios de alto nivel pero
también funcionarios de menor nivel que
han estado involucrados en la represión
violenta de los manifestantes que pueden
haber pensado que podían esconderse
detrás del anonimato pero vamos a
nombrarlos y denunciarlos también y al
mismo tiempo vamos a perseguir a los que
intentan censurar y vigilar al pueblo
iraní a los manifestantes iraníes Así
que justo hoy impusimos más sanciones el
día 40 tras la trágica muerte de mancha
a mini
podrían esas sanciones implicar al
presidente raíz y por ejemplo es lo que
piden algunos funcionarios de Estados
Unidos
él ya está sancionado seguro que usted
lo sabe y lo está desde hace tiempo
algunos sugieren también la creación de
un mecanismo de la ONU para hacer un
seguimiento de los abusos como los que
existen para Siria y nyang
estaría Estados Unidos a favor de crear
un mecanismo de este tipo para lo que
está ocurriendo ahora mismo en Irán
estamos explorando todo tipo de
mecanismos internacionales con nuestros
aliados en todo el mundo Obviamente con
nuestros aliados europeos pero también
con Aliados del sur global muchos de los
cuales se han indignado por lo que han
visto suceder en la represión violenta
contra manifestantes pacíficos Así que
estamos estudiando Qué podemos hacer
para asegurarnos de que los responsables
de esta violenta represión rindan
cuentas también hay obviamente una serie
de sanciones por el supuesto papel de
Irán en Ucrania
se ha hablado mucho de drones iraníes
utilizados por Rusia
incluso del personal militar iraní en
crimea para ayudar a Moscú a realizar
esos ataques con drones en Ucrania
ha visto más indicaciones de una
participación de Irán con Rusia
primero que todo digamos y dejemos claro
lo que sabemos sabemos que Irán ha
estado proporcionando drones docenas de
drones cientos quizás a Rusia sabemos
que han estado formando a los operadores
rusos y sabemos que esos drones han sido
utilizados por Rusia para atacar a
civiles e infraestructuras civiles por
último sabemos que esto avergüenza tanto
a los iraníes que siguen mintiendo ante
las crecientes pruebas de la
transferencia de estos drones la
comunidad internacional en su conjunto
está enfocada en esto porque es
realmente extraordinario ver a Irán
participando en esta guerra de agresión
injustificada de Rusia contra Ucrania
con un gran costo para el pueblo
ucraniano Seguiremos sancionando a
cualquiera que esté involucrado en esas
transferencias y Seguiremos presentando
todas las pruebas que tenemos pero la
situación está siendo lo suficientemente
Clara un experto testificó ante las
Naciones Unidas para todos está claro lo
que está pasando en primer lugar para el
pueblo ucraniano que es víctima de esos
drones y trabajamos para configurarlos
te que Irán también tenga que rendir
cuentas por esa acción
usted dirigió las conversaciones
indirectas con Irán sobre su programa
nuclear teniendo en cuenta lo que está
ocurriendo en estos momentos esas
conversaciones se terminaron o
simplemente están suspendidas
no están en la agenda martes seamos
claro nos enfocamos en donde hay avances
no ha habido avances en las
conversaciones nucleares desde
septiembre irán a preferido una posición
que es totalmente incompatible con la
reactivación del acuerdo Así que nos
enfocamos en donde hay avances y El
Avance está en las calles dirán Porque
estos manifestantes han salido todos los
días pacíficamente y los ojos del mundo
están puestos en el otro asunto que
usted mencionó que es la transferencia
por parte de Irán de drones que están
siendo usados por Rusia para matar
ucranianos en eso nos enfocamos porque
es lo que está sucediendo mientras
hablamos Entonces ya no hay
negociaciones con Irán sobre la cuestión
nuclear en estos momentos correcto
hace tiempo que no hay negociaciones Eso
es correcto el 23 de octubre el ministro
de asuntos exteriores iraní dijo que
Irán había recibido el mensaje de
Estados Unidos tres días antes es decir
el 20 de octubre dijo que Estados Unidos
tenía prisa de llegar a un acuerdo con
Irán le transmitió ustedes ese mensaje a
Teherán
Por supuesto que no estos son los mismos
que dicen que marcha mini murió por
causas naturales son los mismos que
niegan que Irán haya transferido drones
a Rusia entonces creo que podemos tomar
todas estas alegaciones como lo que son
si tuviéramos que transmitir un mensaje
a Irán sería muy sencillo dejen de matar
a su gente Y dejen de transferir drones
a Rusia para matar ucranianos ese sería
nuestro mensaje el resto es tan cierto
como las otras acusaciones a las que me
he referido
lo que parece ser cierto y usted aludió
a eso es que estuvieron muy muy cerca de
un acuerdo en agosto según funcionarios
iraníes europeos y estadounidenses y
Esto fue antes de la represión que llevó
a la situación que acabamos de discutir
Qué ocurrió
lo que sucedió es muy simple y no somos
Solo nosotros los europeos dijeron lo
mismo incluida la Unión Europea que era
la mediadora Irán de repente cambió el
rumbo puso sobre la mesa exigencias que
son completamente incompatibles con la
vuelta al plan de acción integral Al
conjunto eso es lo que pasó y por eso
nuestro enfoque ahora mismo Está en lo
que parece importarle al pueblo iraní
que es protestar contra el régimen y
también la situación entre Rusia e irán
con la transferencia de esos drones
mortales
antes mencionó el internet
Estados Unidos también está
flexibilizando las sanciones a las
empresas tecnológicas que pueden ayudar
a los ciudadanos iraníes a eludir el
control iraní sobre internet obviamente
está el ejemplo de Ucrania donde elon
musk puso a disposición los terminales
starling es esto lo que Estados Unidos
tiene en mente para ayudar al pueblo
iraní a comunicarse entre sí y con el
mundo exterior
es esto básicamente lo que está
preparando
siento no poder profundizar en los
detalles lo que sí puedo decir es que he
estado en contacto con las empresas de
forma bastante directa desde que
anunciamos esta licencia que facilitaría
a las empresas tecnológicas la
asistencia a los iraníes que quieran
comunicarse que quieran escapar de la
censura que su gobierno intenta imponer
y por eso estamos hablando con estas
empresas para decirles que no vamos a
sancionar actividades que antes podían
considerar sancionables estamos
flexibilizando eso para asegurarnos de
que los iraníes tengan la mayor
disponibilidad posible para comunicarse
entre ellos En un momento en el que su
gobierno Está tratando de impedirlo y
puedan comunicarlo al mundo exterior y
escuchar al mundo exterior en un momento
en el que están demostrando tanto coraje
en la lucha por sus libertades
fundamentales solo el último asunto
la cuestión de los ciudadanos de Estados
Unidos y de otros países occidentales
retenidos en Irán Irán liberó a un
estadounidense reciente
se sigue hablando de la liberación de su
hijo si ama de otros ciudadanos
estadounidenses también sabemos que
Francia tiene por ejemplo cinco
ciudadanos que considera Rehenes en Irán
sigue Irán hablando indirectamente con
usted de liberarlos para conseguir tal
vez algún alivio de toda la presión que
está recibiendo en estos momentos
para empezar creo que tenemos que
señalar lo indignante que es que Irán
utiliza personas inocentes como peones
usted mencionó los franceses también hay
personas de otros países de Europa y
tres de nuestros ciudadanos
también está imat y morat Ninguno de los
tres debió haber sido encarcelado en
primer lugar deberían ser liberados lo
antes posible y reunirse con sus seres
queridos
no tenemos más tiempo Muchas gracias por
haber estado aquí en la entrevista de
France 24 a ustedes gracias por vernos y
quédense con nosotros para más noticias
[Música]